Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Cuphead.
So, I think we might actually be pretty close to done with this Island,
I don't actually know where there would be anyone else unless they're up over this yonder way,
but it looks like that's a nope. I think I got everybody here, so, LEMME THROUGH! I gotta get to the next Isle!
Inkwell Isle Three...
Hello, hi, hello, how you doing? "Looks like I might have underestimated ya, Cupface.
You gave it to them debtors but good. Go on over to the next Island.
Lotsa fun times waiting for you there, HA HA HA!"
Alright, thank you. Can't wait to kill you. Okay. See ya.
Boy,  you... you... this...  this really paints the picture of how casinos destroy lives. "The little mugs have some fight in 'em,
I'll say that much! They're making mincemeat out of them debtors!"
"You see! I knew there was something special about those fellas!" "Well, don't be too sure just yet, boss,
I think there's something fishy about those two."
"Don't blow your wig, Dice. If those two little finks try anything...I'll be waiting!!!" ...for them. *evil laugh*
Okay, all right, well, that's ominous of you. But! I've got some tricks up my sleeve of my own,
so I'll have you know that you're stupid, and I'm gonna punch you in your face and dick in that order.
Okay, Honeycomb Herald, alright. What have you got for me? I just love the way you just roll right in the bah--- oh...
Okay, this is gonna suck. This is gonna suck. I can already tell: this is this gon--- this is gon--- oh
Sergeant Bee Dude: Oi, oi, oi!
Hey, hey, hey, woah! God, everything is hard to see here. Ah... woah! Hey, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Alright, alright, alright. Man, this is a depressing work environment.
Aw, I could have slappahd that, but I was too busy worrying about my survival. YEAGH, too high for the slappah---
Oh, no, you got a bruised shoulder. I'm not sad at all about that. Okay. Ah? What are you doing?
What's that all about? Don't be like that! What are you doing? Oh.
Woah, wait! Oh--- Woah, A-I-I-I Oh, uh oh.
Are those slappahble? Ayiay, yee, I'm gonna try! Here we go! No, no NO!
Ah! God, I was totally fine, and then I---I---
I goofed it. Oh, that--- that's weird. Okay, you know what? I don't like that. At all. Woah, okay, that's no good.
You know, I gotta admit, Queen Bee,
Your, your powers are a little bizarre and odd and peculiar, but whatever you say. I guess it's good.
Uh, no, no, no.That looks pink and---
slappahble!
I'm gonna try! I'm not gonna try! I lied! Aahuhuh--- ah!
I can't slappah, can't slappah. They look slappahble, but you know--- no-o, no, no, no, that's not slappahble. That is not s---
I am not your dinner, okay? I'm not, I swear. Sergeant Bee Dude: Oi, oi, oi!
Mark, mocking the Sergeant:Oi! Oi, what's going on here? Ah!
*The frustrated sounds of a wild Markimoo* I don't know. You know what? That was--- I can't do--- let that stand. Mark, mocking the announcer: Now, go!
...I guess, whatever you say, buddy... boo Jim. Where you going? Nope... ah, I could have slappahed that.
But better to play it safe, I suppose.  Oh, hey, woah, that's--- that's a might bit close.
*Weird noise of surprise* No! Ahhhh!
I wasn't watching where my footing was. God, I'm killing these poor worker bees.
This is so sad. (It kinda is, now that you mention it. Everyone who's beaten this level and shit a worker bee, you have murdered someone. I hope you're happy.)
They just come in here with their menial jobs and their lifetime of servitude,
And I just gotta be a dick and shoot 'em. Man, I am an a-hole. That much was evident, I guess.
Wait, what is--- oh! No! Oh, what the hell? What, I don't get the right platforms? (Yes, apparently.)
Huh? You gonna take the platforms away from me? It's not actually my skill that's undermining me?
You--- your platform bullshit. Come on. What do you got? That's gonna be the weird spheres. I don't like the spheres.
I especially don't like the fact that they're pink and look slappahble!
They are slappahble!
But I can't run into them when I slappah. All right, one more time, one more time, one more time.
This is gonna be the one, this is gonna be the one, this is gonna be the one, this is gonna be the one.
Mark mocking the Sargent at high speed: OIOIOIOIOIOIOIOIOI!
No, I jumped into it! Goddamn it! Goddamn it. Goddamn it. I still got this.
Also, why is there---
Why is there a whole hive full of boiling honey? That seems... that seems bizarre and unnecessary.
But like, a lot of things in this world seem pretty bizarre and unnecessary, so I guess I shouldn't complain about...
Ah! Ah, well, that's me. I'm gonna die this round, huh? Yes I am, yes I am.
I just want to see the third phase, though. That's all I really want to--- oh,
hello... (Hi!)
SLAPPAH! No... ah! Ha, ha! Dodge yo--- ah!
Hi-yah! Are you gonna do the triangles? I don't like the triangles.
Oh, I hate the triangles. Actually, if I have to be perfectly honest about something in this place that I actually hate,
it might be the triangles. Well, that's that's different. (What, you're telling me you've never seen a magic queen bee turn into a plane before?)
Nope. Ha-BLALALALALALALALALALA!
Aah, take my milk! I think... I think that's what you're taking. Ah! That's not good. Oh, don't like that. I don't know, it's a--ahhhhh...
Nope, don't like that. Nope, do not like that. Wh--- wh--- aah! AAH! Don't like that at all!
No... oh...
This is the opposite of good. I mean, they're not too hard to dodge--- woah, woah! Woah, I did it! Wh- I did it! I did it! What? WHAT?
Hell yeah, look at me! Look how good I am! Is everybody looking at how good I am? I'm so good! I did that! Hell yeah!  Oh, get rekt!
Oh hell yeah, I didn't parry a goddamn thing, but hell yeah! I don't even know what skill levels are about but hell yeah!
Hell yeah. Yeah, get rekt, bee bi-i-i-i-itch! (Her name is The Royal Witch and Attack Plane Rumor Honeybottoms.)
That was an office building. Was it--- okay, I don't believe that for a second. Well, Rumor Honeybottoms.
Oh, okay, all right. Poor Rumor. Rumor is extremely dead now. Well, hello pirate. Aren't you cute? ...you funko. (That was an insult, I think.)
"Arr! You're gonna need some tips if you want to keelhaul these deadbeats! Start by mixin' up yer weaponry!
Can't expect all yer arms to work for the
same on every foe! Mix and match, landlubbers!
That's what I say!" All right. Well, if you say so, I'm gonna go change up to...
...Charge. Precision is key. I think that might be fun. Or aggravating. One of the two. (How about both? That's the very definition of this game.)
I always get the two mixed up. All right, how about you landlubbers?
"Shootin N' Lootin"? All right. I'm down.
Let me shoot and let me loot. (Okay, just leave the cheese unharmed.) All right, I don't know how this one works. Boink! Ooh!
I like it. Hup! That was dodgeable.
Labooski! I hope that hit you. Heh, I don't even know that hit you.
Oh, it's not! I didn't hit you at all. I'm sorry. (Don't apoligize for not hitting the boss, that's counterproductive.) I didn't even come close to hitting you. That's not good.
Woah, woah, woah! What the hell? Woah, woah, woah, woah. What the hell? Woah, woah, woah, dogfish? That ain't... that ain't right. Okay, how about this again?
DOUBLEBLAST! Okay, now it hit ya. Wha-who? Wha?  Oh, where did that come from?
Oh, I see it. Oh no! Ah shit, shit, shitty tits!
Man that's pretty good for my first try. Not bad, ok. Easy enough. Let me try the other one.
Oh see, yeah this is gonna be, that's gonna be a problem because, I can't just like always focus in on that. HABLULULULULU
There we go, that's how you do. This guy seems pretty easy, I'm not gonna lie. I mean, I'm not gonna
jinx it or anything, but. Woah!
Woah okay, never mind.  Not easy, not easy, not easy, not easy. HABOOOM!
So I just gotta be mindful when he whistles, 'cuz that's when he calls assistance.
Uh-oh, that don't look good, that...doh that's not good.
I don't know what that is.  Oh woah, woah, woah, what the hell? Woah, woah,
woah, oh! woah, woah, woah buddy, woah, woah! Haw-haw-haw-haw! Yeah, whatever. Shuddup man.
Alright, I know what to do here. This must do a lot of damage. Like, I'm not gonna lie,
this must do like an incredible amount of damage.
Not bad, not bad. Easy. (You say that now, but just wait for later in the game.)  Oh, shark incoming. Okay. I know that.
Whoa? Ha-BLALALALALALALA!
Okay, come on, give me another.
It sure does love to give me the slappahs. *Runs into one of the slappahs it gave him.* Oh, goddamn it.
Well, I don't know what happened there, but that was--- that was not good.
Oh, goddamn. Wow. (SURPRISE AERIAL ATTACK!) OH! Holy shit!
Oh!
WOAH! What? I didn't even know about that! Oh, so close! Goddamn it, I had to duck.
All right, I got this, I got this, I got this I got this, I got this. "Wallop". I know.
All right, dogs incoming, along with cannonballs.
All good.Ducking, ducking, ducking, ducking, ducking, ducking! That pink beam. Seems like you could slappah like a bunch.
Oh, God,  I was looking right at the wrong place. Oh, I'm flustered.
Ducking!
*He ducks. The ship shoots its uvula laser. Whoever came up with the bosses' ideas and weapons deserves a raise.*
HEYYYYYYYYY! Get rekt, bitch! Oh, yeah, I love this gun. I love this gun, this gun is good.
This gun is *kisses hand like a chef*. Just wait for the right opportunity, and you hit him hard.
I love that gun. That is a good gun. That is a good gun. That's a good gun. That's a good gun right there.
Wha-bam-bam-bam-bam That's a good gun.
(Calm down there, Wilford.)
I still haven't managed to A+ anything, but that is a damn good gun.
But then again, that one seemed a lot easier than a lot of the other ones so --- *takes a long sip of water to drink away his problems.*
Mark, imitating the flag raise jingle: CUPHEAAAAAAAD!
Okay, Captain Brinybeard, who is, by all accounts, a human in this weird world of...
...creatures and cups. All right, what do we got here? "Perilous Piers". Well, I don't know about that. I imagine it's gonna be perfectly wonderful.
Oh, it's so satisfying, too.
(unintelligible), and it gives tons of super per hit.
*Does not get any supers per hit.*
Never mind, apparently
No, it gives no--- none super. What the hell? No, come here, you. Not--- not now you're getting slapping
...creatures and cups. All right, what do we got here? "Perilous Piers". Well, I don't know about that. I imagine it's gonna be perfectly wonderful.
Oh, it's so satisfying, too.
(unintelligible), and it gives tons of super per hit.
*Does not get any supers per hit.*
Never mind, apparently
No, it gives no--- none super. What the hell? No, come here, you. No, no, no, you're getting slappahed.
Urgh, but if you don't hit your target it's next to useless, I guess.
Wragh!
Come on, you, you're being a bit of a sassy. Come on, work.
Woah, WHAT? Oh!
That's--- yeah, that seems about right.
Did everyone else die when I died? Is that, like, just a law in this land? (It's because you are all spiritually linked under the goddess Rumor Honeybottoms.)
It's like, bosses, I'm fine with, bosses are just like you run, and you blast them a few times, you learn their mechanics,
but for like levels like this, I don't know why I have so much trouble. Maybe it's because I'm terrible. Oh, wait.
I just rem--- guys, I realized the problem. The answer is I'm terrible. (18 million people beg to differ.) Forgot, forgot, forgot. I totally forgot about that fact about--- *makes horse lips sound*
See, see what I mean? See what I mean, guys?
Woooow, okay, all right, yeah, the easiest part. It's always the easiest parts--- like that! It's always the easiest parts that I die.
God, I'm so stupid. It's also a really cool feature how you you shoot when you dash with this thing.
You kind of dash and like let go so you can dash and
blast an enemy at the same time. Very useful, very very useful. I'm also being extremely facetious.
It's not--- oh, come on. See, the easiest ones, the easiest moments are the only ones that actually... (Actually what? I'm dying to know!)
Slappah! Oh, WHAT? Oh god, I didn't go high enough? Really? AAH!
Goddamn slappah BITCH.
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!
Why? That was--- those not intentional in any way.
I just happened to be three counts of stupid in a row. I ran away from a fish in fear.
I didn't think I'd ever do that in my life, but I honestly ran out of--- well.
Wow, I am just sucking back tit right now, and I don't know why.
No! Ah, come on, you sack of shit!
Goddamn you!
Oh, God, Gooooooooddamnit.
Ah, god!
Oh, fuck, why is this one so hard? This is not hard!
You know, I think it's because I'm trying to be fancy with the gun.
It's gonna go with the goddamn run and gun, and that's it. I don't care if it takes longer to kill.
Okay, maybe I do care if it takes longer to kill, because holy shit, why does that take so long?
*Dramatic sigh* See, a little better, a little better, huh, a little better, a little better, oddly, a little better. No, oh! Shit! Oh!
Uh-oh. *The wild Markimoo danger call sounds.*
What? Two? I didn't even know I could do two! I don't even know I could do two of those in a row! Okay, very close this is...
I don't trust this at all.
Wh--- no, why didn't I...? Why didn't I dash there, then?
Why didn't I dash there? Oh, you've got to be kidding me.
Well you've got to be yanking on my gourd. (What?) Okay, here we go, here we go, here we go, here we go. The good stuff.
What we call at Markiplier HQ "The Good Stuff™."
Oh, I see why. Oh, wait. Wait, how? Wait, what?
Wait... oh, on your head! I didn't know that that was what's going on here. I was just--- I was under the impression...
Oh my god, I have no idea what's happening here. I am so scared, and I--- I am just lost to the winds
Okay, you know--- ah God! I didn't--- I had no idea that's what was happening.. fuuuuuck!
I had no idea that's what was happening there. I am--- I'm just you know--- I just don't know.
I don't know what's going on in this world.
Also, might I add this pier is disgusting. The freaking flying fish infestation is just beyond terrible.
Like, if I saw all these,
like, barnacles on the sidewalk with eyes that were spewing green gook,
I would be very concerned. You know, I just--- I want to come out and say it.
I know it's taking a stance,
but I would be a little concerned... more than a little. I'd be--- I'd have to call--- I'd have to call City Council meeting
if I saw this. This is disgusting. Okay here we go. Oh, I see you in there.
Oh, you thought I missed you. Okay.
Good thing I died all those other times so that I could actually see that. I'm really happy about that.
Okay, now I'm standing on your head. I get it. Okay. Go! Go, my favorite friend... my favorite friend in the whole wide world. Bonk.
Do you go faster if I bonk you?
*Bonks his best friend in the world.*
Wh-no! Come on! You made me miss the goddamn coin, you----AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA! Fucking--- what the fuck?!
I fall apart  right at the end here? Really? Really? The fucking end? I missed the goddamn coin. It was right in front of me. (Unintelligible.)
(Unintelligible). GOD!
Fuck! AH! I'm not gonna do it. I'm gonna start over cuz fuck that. That is so stupid and you're stupid. *Another dramatic sigh.*
I'm getting--- I'm getting salty, guys, get it? cuz I'm at a pier...
(Just cuz we get it doesn't make it funny.)
What the hell, what the hell, what the hell, no! Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah!
What the hell? Where you think you you came from, huh?
What do you think you came from, huh?
Your mother? No, no, no, no, nothing that ugly could have birthed something as pretty as you, and let's consider that an insult or
something. I don't know. I don't know what it was, really. Save this bouncy bounce for when I need it.
No! I didn't save the--- no! I didn't--- I'm gonna get it--- oh, FUCK OFF!
Ah, fuck you!
I didn't say--- I said it in my brain "save the bouncy bounce for when you need it, Marki-pliy-yuhr."
Ugh, fucking... I call myself Markiplier in my brain, by the way. This is what I do.
Like, why is this level getting me more agitated  than any other level that I've faced?
It's just I--- *strands of gibberish as Mark tries to form a full sentence.* I've beaten it already. I've beaten it twice now. It's just a fucking coin
I don't even know. I'm not even a completionist type. It's just that it insulted me. That's really all it--- is this was insulting.
No come on. I want to do this flawless. I'm getting a fucking A+ on this. I don't care who you are.
I don't--- really don't care. You're gonna get--- you're gonna give me that A+.
You're gonna give me that A+, perfect, on time, skill, everything about me is so beautifully done. Oh, yeah, oh yeah. WHYYYY?
UUUREGGHHH! I don't even want the A--- why do I want the A+? I've beaten this already!
I didn't have any standards before this, as you all know. I don't have standards. I just don't. It's not a part of me.
It's not what I do. It's not how I am
All right, usually, I'm just totally fine with mediocrity, like mediocrity is really like it's the bread and butter of my life, you know?
Just--- good enough is like *Markihen returns as Mark temporarily forgets how to speak.* a slogan that---
Fuck you, you piece of shit fish! You cock fish! That's what you are! You piece of cock!
Ah! I don't know why--- I don't know why I want this. I do not know why I want this. I actually don't want this.
Fucking--- now I'm in a hurry.
And I'm never gonna get it because I'm in a hurry and there's nothing I can do. I can't not be in a hurry for this.
I am just going to fuck it up now.
Like, that's just my lot in life right now. I am gonna fuck this up. See? God!
It's like, why am I in a hurry? I don't--- I really don't need to be in a hurry. It's not something
that's a requirement right now.
No, come on! Why am I in a hurry? Why?
Stop being in a hurry, you piece of shit me! (Mark, don't talk about yourself that way!) Meself. Me has talked to meself to stop being in a goddamn
hurry. If I just--- if I--- oh fucking hell! Oh my god, why am I so--- why am I so like this?
Why am I like this? Why am I like this? I --- you guys are asking the same question, WhY aM I lIkE tHiS?
Why am I like this? Why? I'm punishing myself
here. NO! AHHHH! AHHH!
I'm punishing nobody but myself. That's the only thing I'm doing here.
I'm making myself angry for no reason. There's absolutely nothing to gain out of this this. The A+ is
meaningless, and I'm not even gonna get it. I guarantee you. I'm gonna find another way to goof this up, okay.
I'm here. It's fine
I just feel--- hit that, hit that, hit that, I hit that, hit that, woah, woah, no! !hat the fuck?
Goddamnit, you didn't tell me that you--- OH, FUCKING FUCK OFF!
No, no, what, no! Goddamnit, I fucking--- what the fuck? God-fucking-damnit!
Just stop, Mark, just--- I'm talking--- I'm begging myself. Just stop being an asshole
Just stop, just get the life level over with and--- oh, really?
Fucking goddamnit, and then I realize, like, there's nothing I can do. My god. There's nothing I can do right now
I'm stuck in a loop until I get this. I don't know why. This is how my brain works.
I become so fixated and I can recognize--- I can know--- I can know it's wrong
I can know what I'm doing is stupid. I know it in my head,
I know it. My body will not understand. My body rejects any
fucking semblance of logic. My brain can be like "this is the stupidest thing I'm doing. Why am I still on this map? I have
beaten this
many times now, and I'm still fucking playing it. Why?" There's no excuse for it. I have no reason. Oh my god.
There's no reason. I cannot get out of this loop. I am not joking. This is not playing up anything. Fucking hell!
This is not playing up anyting. I cannot fucking stop. This is just my curse. I just can't do it.
This is how I am as a person if you want any insight to me as a person,
This is me because I can't fucking let it go.
(I could make a Frozen joke here, but this seems serious.)
I don't let I let things go. It's not that I don't let things go that bothers me.
I can very easily when it comes to real life shit,
I can let it go, but when something thinks that it's fucking better than me, oh you better fucking believe
I'm gonna go the ends of the earth to make sure you burn to the ground you piece of shit
I will destroy my entire life to prove someone wrong oh
god
*assorted no's*
No, I was there, I had it! God damn it, god  fucking damn it! Damn it! Fuck!
I don't want it. I don't want it. I don't want it. It's unhealthy to want it. It's unhealthy to want it.
I just want to finish this.
That's how fucking close I was.
Why, why, why was I stuck in that loop?
I don't know why. I know
I could have done that. I know I could have. Probably just one more try and I would have had it.
But why did I put myself through that?
I wouldn't have gotten an A anyway. I wouldn't have got it, 'cause I didn't parry enough apparently. God. I don't understand---
I don't understand myself. I don't understand, but that's all the time I got for this episode of Cuphead. I'm sorry
it was so stressful at the end there, but think of how stressful it was for me.
Please have mercy on me. I am a weird individual, and I can't control these things. I want to very badly.
Anyway thank you everybody so much for watching. It's the reason why I'm not giving up on this and it's weird--- the reason
why I'm not giving up on "Getting Over It", so.Thank you everyone so much for watching.
And as always, I will see you in the next video. Buh-bye!
Closed captioning done by someone awesome!
And it's their first time captioning a video, too!